cbs news medical contributor dr david
agus joins us now
good morning dr aegis you heard that
just now and you know that
uh president trump is saying there's a
possibility we could have a vaccine
before or around november how likely is
that
first of all i hate when the vaccines
get politicized the clinical trials are
ongoing now and nobody knows in advance
how many cases there will be and how
well the vaccine will work
so it really is impossible to say when
the vaccine is going to be available
well
one of the clinical trials the
astrazeneca oxford trial was started a
while ago in south africa brazil and the
united kingdom
and has accrued a significant number of
cases so my gut is that will be the
first one
to yield a result and we'll see what the
data show
any ideas as to when that would be the
first to go
i think it's possible that we could see
this vaccine data
in september or october which means that
we would have a vaccine sooner remember
every day sooner we have a vaccine
that's a thousand or more lives saved in
the united states
for people who are still trying to sort
of make sense of this
what are i mean you say it could save
more lives but in terms of
how this vaccine would work and how
effective this vaccine is we've heard
that dr
anthony fauci said that the efficacy
rate could be about 60
explain that and how effective that
these new vaccines could be these early
ones
so these vaccines take a piece of the
virus
and they inject it into you and then you
make an immune response which protects
you from the whole virus the active
virus
what the fda has publicly said is you
have to reduce symptoms
of covin19 by 50 or more to be approved
that's the metric
fauci had said we hope it's 60 so it's
not going to eliminate the virus but it
will
in many cases make it so you're not
symptomatic in other cases where you
would have been hospitalized
you'll just have a bad cold and i'll
take that any day of the week over what
we're seeing now
the pain and the suffering with this
virus and this isn't just you take a
shot and you're done
correct this would be two shots
right now the vaccine candidates are a
day one shot and either
three or four weeks later what we call a
booster shot
when you do that booster the immune
system makes a much more powerful
response
both antibodies and t cells to fight the
virus
and we know that moderna and pfizer
started their phase three trials last
week and this is the last phase what
happens
in that final phase of vaccine testing
so the final phase so three are in that
we're considering the united states the
astrozenica the moderna and the pfizer
and half the people get a basically a
water shot
a salt water shot and half the people
get the vaccine and then they look at
symptoms associated with cova 19 in both
groups when it hits statistical
significance
bang the fda will review the data and
we'll get it out
in the first week for example in the
modernist study about 1200 people signed
up
30 000 people are needed for the study
so at this rate
accrual is slow we need quicker accrual
on the trial people have to step up and
be heroes
and be a part of the solution here in
the united states
you just heard earlier too that ohio
governor mike dewine tested positive
then he tested negative
he had the antigen and then the pcr test
can you explain the difference and what
does that say about where we are with
testing
this is a you know high official who got
tested and one thing
showed something and then a totally
different test within 24 hours
i'm with you tarika this is an issue the
antigen test
is a quicker less expensive test
that is slightly lower on what we call
sensitivity it can miss some positive
cases
in this case it was the opposite it
called a test positive the pcr test more
specific
classically takes hours or days um to
get the result back
but it was negative so why was there a
false positive with an antigen
i don't know was it a problem with how
it was run or something of the kind the
samples were mixed up i
really don't know and it's an issue and
if this is happening to the head of a
state can you imagine what's happening
in testing to everybody in the country
so we certainly need to continue to
improve on testing in this country
do you think pcr is better because
you're you're looking at what's
in the nose and the throat and the
respiratory area
well for the antigen test and the pcr
they both take a swab from the nose
the uh antigen test looks for a protein
on the virus whereas the pcr test
amplifies the genetic material so that
amplification test
makes it more sensitive if you're
looking if you're infectious
they're both good if you're looking if
you have the virus at all
pcr is a better test okay dr david agus
thank you so much